In this video we're going
to talk a little bit about
order of operations.
And I want you to pay close
attention because really
everything else that you're
going to do in mathematics
is going to be based on you
having a solid grounding
in order of operations.
So what do we even mean when
we say order of operations?
So let me give you an example.
The whole point is so that we
have one way to interpret
a mathematical statement.
So let's say I have the
mathematical statement
7 plus 3 times 5.
Now if we didn't all agree on
order of operations, there
would be two ways of
interpreting this statement.
You could just read it left to
right, so you could say well,
let me just take 7 plus 3, you
could say 7 plus 3 and then
multiply that times 5.
And 7 plus 3 is 10, and then
you multiply that by 5.
10 times 5, it
would get you 50.
So that's one way you would
interpret it if we didn't agree
on an order of operations.
Maybe it's a natural way.
You just go left to right.
Another way you could interpret
it you say, I like to do
multiplication before
I do addition.
So you might interpret it as --
I'll try to color code it --
7 plus -- and you do
the 3 times 5 first.
7 plus 3 times 5, which would
be 7 plus 3 times 5 is
15, and 7 plus 15 is 22.
So notice, we interpreted
this statement in
two different ways.
This was just straight left
to right doing addition
then the multiplication.
This way we did the
multiplication first then the
addition, we got two different
answers, and that's just not
cool in mathematics.
If this was part of some effort
to send something to the moon
because two people interpreted
it a different way or another
one computer interpreted one
way and another computer
interpreted it another way, the
satellite might go to mars.
So this is just completely
unacceptable, and that's why
we have to have an agreed
upon order of operations.
An agreed upon way to
interpret this statement.
So the agreed upon order of
operations is to do parentheses
first -- let me write it over
here -- then do exponents.
If you don't know what
exponents are don't worry
about it right now.
In this video we're not going
to have any exponents in our
examples, so you don't
really have to worry about
them for this video.
Then you do multiplication --
I'll just right mult, short for
multiplication -- then you do
multiplication and division
next, they kind of have the
same level of priority.
And then finally you do
addition and subtraction.
So what does this order of
operations -- let me label
it -- this right here,
that is the agreed upon
order of operations.
If we follow these order of
operations we should always
get to the same answer
for a given statement.
So what does this tell us?
What is the best way to
interpret this up here?
Well we have no parentheses --
parentheses look like that.
Those little curly
things around numbers.
We don't have any
parentheses here.
I'll do some examples that
do have parentheses.
We don't have any
exponents here.
But we do have some
multiplication and division
or we actually just have
some multiplication.
So we'll order of operations,
do the multiplication
and division first.
So it says do the
multiplication first.
That's a multiplication.
So it says do this
operation first.
It gets priority over
addition or subtraction.
So if we do this first we
get the 3 times 5, which is
15, and then we add the 7.
The addition or subtraction --
I'll do it here, addition,
we just have addition.
Just like that.
So we do the multiplication
first, get 15, then
add the 7, 22.
So based upon the agreed order
of operations, this right
here is the correct answer.
The correct way to
interpret this statement.
Let's do another example.
I think it'll make things a
little bit more clear, and
I'll do the example in pink.
So let's say I have 7 plus 3 --
I'll put some parentheses there
-- times 4 divided by
2 minus 5 times 6.
So there's all sorts of crazy
things here, but if you just
follow the order of operations
you'll simplify it in a very
clean way and hopefully we'll
all get the same answer.
So let's just follow the
order of operations.
The first thing we have to
do is look for parentheses.
Are there parentheses here?
Yes, there are.
There's parentheses
around the 7 plus 3.
So it says let's do that first.
So 7 plus 3 is 10.
So this we can simplify,
just looking at this
order operations, to
10 times all of that.
Let me copy and paste
that so I don't have
to keep re-writing it.
So that simplifies to
10 times all of that.
We did our parentheses first.
Then what do we do?
There are no more parentheses
in this expression.
Then we should do exponents.
I don't see any exponents here,
and if you're curious what
exponents look like, an
exponent would look
like 7 squared.
You'd see these little small
numbers up in the top right.
We don't have any exponents
here so we don't have
to worry about it.
Then it says to do
multiplication and
division next.
So where do we see
multiplication?
We have a multiplication,
a division, a
multiplication again.
Now, when you have multiple
operations at the same level,
when our order of operations,
multiplication and division
are the same level, then
you do left to right.
So in this situation you're
going to multiply by 4
and then divide by 2.
You won't multiply
by 4 divided by 2.
Then we'll do the 5 times
6 before we do the
subtraction right here.
So let's figure
out what this is.
So we'll do this
multiplication first.
We could simultaneously do this
multiplication because it's
not going to change things.
But I'll do things
one step at a time.
So the next step we're going
to do is this 10 times 4.
10 times 4 is 40.
10 times 4 is 40, then you
have 40 divided by 2 and it
simplifies to that right there.
Remember, multiplication and
division, they're at the exact
same level so we're going
to do it left to right.
You could also express this as
multiplying by 1/2 and then it
wouldn't matter the order.
But for simplicity,
multiplication and division
go left to right.
So then you have 40 divided
by 2 minus 5 times 6.
So, division, you just
have one division here,
you want to do that.
You have this division and you
have this multiplication,
they're not together so you
can actually kind of do
them simultaneously.
And to make it clear that you
do this before you do the
subtraction because
multiplication and division
take priority over addition and
subtraction, we could put
parentheses around them to say
look, we're going to do that
and that first before I do that
subtraction, because
multiplication and
division have priority.
So 40 divided by 2 is 20.
We're going to have that minus
sign, minus 5 times 6 is 30.
20 minus 30 is equal
to negative 10.
And that is the correct
interpretation of that.
So I want to make something
very, very, very clear.
If you have things at the same
level, so if you have 1 plus
2 minus 3 plus 4 minus 1.
So addition and subtraction are
all the same level in order of
operations, you should
go left to right.
So you should interpret this as
1 plus 2 is 3, so this is the
same thing as 3 minus
3 plus 4 minus 1.
Then you do 3 minus 3
is 0 plus 4 minus 1.
Or this is the same thing
as 4 minus 1, which is
the same thing as 3.
You just go left to right.
Same thing if you have
multiplication and division,
they're at the same level.
So if you have 4 times 2
divided by 3 times 2,
you do 4 times 2 is 8
divided by 3 times 2.
And you say 8 divided by 3 is,
well, we got a fraction there.
It would be 8/3.
So this would be 8/3 times 2.
And then 8/3 times to
is equal to 16 over 3.
That's how you interpret it.
You don't do this
multiplication first or divide
the 2 by that and all of that.
Now the one time where you can
be loosey-goosey with order of
operations, if you have all
addition or all multiplication.
So if you have 1 plus 5 plus 7
plus 3 plus 2, it does not
matter what order you do it in.
You can do the 2 plus 3, you
can go from the right to the
left, you can go from the
left to the right, you could
start some place in between.
If it's only all addition.
And the same thing is true if
you have all multiplication.
It's 1 times 5 times
7 times 3 times 2.
It does not matter what
order you're doing it.
But it's only with all
multiplication or all addition.
If there was some division
in here, if there's some
subtraction in here, you're
best off just going
left to right.